okay let's do sarawan just first this is
a little bit more manageable and this I
actually know how to play but for those
that don't know how to play essentially
there's two additional pieces
each player has two extra pieces in
their peace Bank
the elephant
combines The Rook in the knights also
known as a Nook
or a Canuck
and the hawk combines a bishop in the
night
when the pieces move for the first time
the elephant or Hawk can be placed on
the vacated Square
okay let's play this
everyone just
three plus two
good luck to prune fellow
and
okay I'll start with E4
so it's only when these pieces move
that I can
place my
Canuck or my Hawk
I should really call it an elephant so
this is a hawk
that's actually nice like the piece
design we can kind of understand
that this is a night Bishop and this is
a rook Knight
so I'll just do I wanna
can I undo move ah okay
okay so I I have my
uh my Hawk and elephant place
a black being a little bit passive here
but
yeah this is going to be a slightly more
crowded board than usual
now I've actually played sarawan Just
against Yasser sarawan
um I believe the St Louis chess club has
like custom handcrafted
Sarah one chess pieces
they actually look pretty cool I'll have
to see if I can find some
and Yasser is like really really good at
this game
it would be cool to get him on stream
and like give a lesson on ceremon chess
because there's some interesting theory
about like meeting with just the hawk
or like cool tactics with the elephant
I don't think Yasser hates online chess
he also actually plays a decent amount
on leechas
um every so often he'll be having like
these intense matches
against stockfish
in crazy house
I'll sometimes see him like playing
like the top crazy house engine trying
to beat it
I believe Yasser did come up with this
I'm not sure exactly when
it would be cool to learn the history
uh oh
I just fall victim uh I can take this
bishop D5 coming
oh okay the hawk has developed
so I assume okay the Hawks are probably
close to the value of the queen
but it is a question like how valuable
are hawks in relation so the queen and
the Elephant
I forgot this is defended
oh that's funny
okay I'll take
elephant comes to V7 now Knight D5
hitting the hawk
oh I just lost a pawn though oops
oh no
I'm so blind to these new pieces
don't punish me
I should develop my own Hawk
okay so I'm hitting the hawk now the
hawk can move like this
but also like this
I'm not gonna win the pawn because of
the elephant defends it
okay I think that's a big mistake
because my Rook was definitely not as
valuable as a hawk
now it's time to show no mercy let's use
my
I really want to call this like a bishop
or something or a mission
has been this whole trend on Anarchy
chess
got these new peace names
okay
a ketchup
using my kishup
okay how do I coordinate effectively
let's just Castle first
I think General chess principles still
apply to this game King safety control
the center
but the tactics in this game are going
to be ridiculous
especially if I can get a meeting attack
with my
condition and my Canuck
I think I'll
wait how I do this
play this first
okay so this Pawn supported a bunch
I'm so confused because these look like
Knights but they're they're special
power nights
let's take this
oh but then my my thing looks at the
queen
okay I'm gonna take with a queen how
about
thank you
so if takes I'll take with my queen I
don't want to lose my special pieces
so D5 is reinforced by
by these two things
I'll just go back to saying Hawk and
elephant
and this this is actually not a great
Square although we might see elephant
disa
oh but then I take
how do I trade my queen for the elephant
probably not necessary
okay let's play this move
activating
I have no sense of Peace coordination
with these things
I want to take but then takes
so let's play
let's play this
I mean you you'd imagine that all these
things will be good at attacking like
maybe I'll just sack a queen
I sack a queen oh no my queen don't know
what this thing can take
I forgot okay that thing didn't take
wait I just miscalculated
ah
wait a minute
okay three plus two
check
okay check
oh no my Canuck
I gotta move
I'm so confused
foreign
hey it's a fork
I don't want to take that because the
Canuck defends the other Queen
scene
don't hurt me
okay don't mess with my Hawk thing
oh no
is that that's not meat this could have
taken me wanna doesn't realize though
hey it's a fork okay
don't mess with my elephant bishop or my
Hawk Bishop my Hawk Knights
my Bishop Knight
there we go okay
uh
uh that's a free rook that's a free rook
okay
uh I really struggled naming the pieces
there
were so many blunders that came too that
was crazy
okay I gotta Play One More
I feel like so much was missed
I assume I'd probably put the the hawk
and elephant also at nine
can I play Stafford gamut
staffer Gammon and sarawan chess
I can't resist
if my opponent loves it
oh angry space Boyd says is my first
game in this
which I don't know how truthful that is
I see this provisional rating
but maybe the breathing is based on like
other ratings
do I need to
okay I'll put in my um
my elephant
oh I know Sapphire Gambit
how do I not do I have to oh continue
okay
yeah because later okay it's after
Gambit time
I'll put this in
okay
and then if it takes I take back
oh we don't have a true staffer though
so I'll play this
attacking the pawn aligning with the
King preparing castling
maybe you're preparing D5 as well
realizing maybe I could count like next
time I should castle and put a an
elephant there
this is getting spicy
I really want to take on
F2
I feel like there's so much sagging
potential but I should first start by
wait
I'm just realizing this defends F2 I
shouldn't take on F2 I should start by
taking here
and then taking
with my elephant
foreign
business
so I'm threatening enough to
Elba my Bishop is attacked
what's happening here oh this is no the
let's only move sideways and in L shapes
I don't know if I want to take on F2
I guess I do though
it wins upon
and puts the king in check so we're
trading elephant for Hawk so now
opponent still has an elephant I have a
hawk
it's a little bit easier to understand
now
I guess we'll see which piece prevails
like this piece is much trickier to
understand
getting some simplified end game
it's definitely not going to be so
simple though
I think you decept
appreciate the first time Prime
opponent wants to hurt me
I mean endgame Theory I'm sure is crazy
in this game
thank you joshiba
okay so let's develop my Hawk
save Square
foreign
trouble
I feel like Hawks are good at attacking
elephants
at least along the diagonals elephants
can be vulnerable
start with this
ah but on files
the Hawks are vulnerable
also I'm kind of skewering these things
could be
a little bit iffy
wow so now I take with check
I control this Square too let's go
where's my duck I want to take the rook
and put a duck on B1
but that's not possible
because I'm calculating this
Rook will defend the other Rook
oh but I can can I pin the
wait a minute
I want to pin the things of the thing
let's start by checking
I'm so paranoid that I'm blundering this
but
this piece can't take
meanwhile this attacks this king is tied
down to the elephant
a king basically has to move
could move there but now I have this
move
oh this is getting wild actually
I'm threatening some nasty discoveries
and the king is tied down still I'm
still attacking it I'm also hitting the
Rook
so I'm starting to take with discover
check
might also be threatening this move
I'm hoping my opponent moves I mean I
want to like have some kind of funny
mate
oh
where's my funny mate
I mean I take the Rook
are there any other like there's night
before
it's so hard to calculate in this game
let's take the Rook with check
and then go back with check
and then I pin
I mean it's already pinned
but I'm gonna win that next move
no mercy here
foreign
okay
yeah tough finish for lights
game